but let's read this news here man let's
talk about rand paul claiming the
election was in many ways stolen
now as all of you know yes let's not
let's not play games
we don't want to get the stream taken
off the air and youtube has said
that if you say certain things in
combination they'll just take down the
clip
what combos like iraq saddam hussein
weapons of mass destruction
that's okay oh that's okay yeah you can
say that you can say those smashed up
yeah yeah you can say you can say uh you
can lie to the american people east
and uh call for a repeated war which
gets us into this 20-year quagmire
and you can claim that trump is a
russian asset still
to this day working for the soviets not
just russia
because they they said 1987. all right
they said 1987
and you you are okay but if you claim
the
two things the first is that there's
widespread voter fraud or error and the
second you combine that with a statement
that it changed the outcome
they remove your content boom just gone
from from youtube
which is really interesting considering
a lot of what's coming out right now and
this statement from rand paul which i
will now read
the hill reports quote the fraud
happened
the election in many ways was stolen and
the only way it will be fixed is by in
the future reinforcing the laws paul
said during a hearing
with testimony from christopher krebs
the president's former cyber security
chief who was fired by trump after he
reported there was no interference in
the election
paul made the remarks as krebs wearing a
mask looked unskeptically his arms
crossed
in front of his chest thanks for that uh
the hill the remarks were notable
because paul is seen as one of the
senators who might join a bid by rhett
moe brooks
to challenge the election's outcome and
overturn the results in several states
despite a series of court decisions that
have rejected claims of widespread fraud
as unsubstantiated
that is false fake news from the hill
most of these cases as far as i know and
it's challenging because there's many
were procedural grounds in fact i'll put
it this way maybe that's true but in the
hearing it was stated by numerous people
that the claims in these lawsuits
pertain to fraud were never actually
ruled on the merits
so they didn't say necessarily it was
unsubstantiated
that there was widespread fraud they
said things like you have no standing
or it's too late to sue or you know this
is a criminal matter that must be
investigated and not for a civil court
or whatever
i'll also point out kris krebs who said
there was no interference
he said specifically from a security
perspective
security because he's a cyber security
guy he said fraud well that's a criminal
matter i have nothing to do with
so that's really important we're talking
about this now
i don't know uh if rand paul actually
actually will step
up especially i don't know if you heard
jack mitch mcconnell basically saying
you know leave trump high and dry don't
do this i don't think we can count on
the gop for support in this matter
as much as i would like to i'm curious
about rand paul going out on a limb here
what do you i mean what do you mean well
you know just he's always sort of been a
renegade right and doing his own thing
and you know he's really making
kind of a stand here him and ted cruz
have really stepped up
taking some action to try to you know
investigate at least see what's
happening
yeah and uh and take a principled stand
i guess ran's comfortable
out there by himself huh he's always
been he's always what do you filibuster
the nda
the defense bill yeah that's supportive
of trump trump says gonna veto i don't
know if he can because
republicans and democrats are alike are
like war good
more war fantastic we don't care what
trump thinks ted cruz started smoking
pot like
six years ago is that your what i don't
know it just seems like he started
smoking pot
he totally changed he used to be this
uptight nerd and then he started growing
a beer now he's like this hippie
republican i mean
something no other explanation yeah he
took mushrooms or something
well come january 6 we're going to find
out
i'm willing to bet the republicans with
absolutely zero political willpower
are going to sit back and be like
dude rand paul is not a republican like
he's a republican but he's not
anything like mitch mcconnell like he's
a completely different
uh uh creature like yeah he is i would
maybe he's like a libertarian just he is
very libertarian
yeah yes he's a lot like his dad but
because the libertarian party has no
representation in our government he's
republicans it's why bernie runs as a
democrat yeah but the interesting thing
about the progressive left is that
bernie
when it became obvious that he wasn't
going to win
or i should say that when he just when
he folded because he should have kept
pushing it
you know he just dropped down and
started licking the feet of the of the
dnc establishment
where trump was like no excuse me excuse
me no
no and then he took over and then the
republicans it was it was inverted it's
interesting
bernie and the progressives were forced
to drop down and
beg the establishment for some kind of
time and and presence
and they barely get any leverage trump
was the other way around
trump took over and the establishment
republicans were like oh
no what do we do you're the trump party
now baby so they had to listen to what
trump wanted you know that they had
they had to get behind trump to the best
you know to a certain extent
and it's really funny how many trump
supporters really did say okay to the
republicans
and now now things are getting totally
different i mean first of all i'll tell
you
when i see memes from trump supporters
mocking police officers i don't know if
you saw this one
because you saw what happened in
michigan where the cop at the state
capitol
wouldn't let the republican elect
electoral candidates sorry
in the building so then all of a sudden
trump supporters posting memes basically
saying these these cops are you know
not heroes they only care about their
paycheck and not the will you know not
the constitution stuff like that
so that sentiment's already changed and
now they're basically
going nuts after mitch mcconnell saying
it's time for him to
you know for a new party leader i think
it's definitely fair to say that the gop
is fractured
and that the political realignment is
happening right now in a very
interesting way where a lot of people
who are anti-establishment are learning
that they have a lot more in common
than they have different from each other
but also very interestingly the
washington examiner also just tweeted
that in nevada there are there are still
legal arguments that quote 42
000 people voted more than once that at
least 1
500 dead people voted and that 19 000
people
uh voted even though they didn't live in
nevada so we're still
still hearing some of these arguments
will they actually translate it that
means something
that was stated under oath yes by a
trump campaign lawyer exactly
so if they think there's no evidence and
he's lying congratulations
you got him the trump campaign lawyer is
going to go to prison for lying
to the senate under oath congratulations
there you go so how about now
we get his files we present them in a
court of law that way you can all send
the trump campaign lawyer to jail how
does that sound
never will happen too much they don't
they don't want these guys
go to court of course they don't want
the merits presented absolutely not no
discovery none of that
yeah when when uh the trump lawsuit i
think was in nevada the judges didn't
even
the court didn't even want to look at
the evidence they were like no no
no we're not going to do that the
supreme court which is in favor of him
which
was selected there's a large number of
people that were selected by him for the
supreme court
that were from the 2000 bush v gore case
they they're like oh we don't want to
hear it as well like like
like what else do what what other you
know writings on the wall
do we need to to see that there's a big
rift within the establishment
i i don't get why the court gets to pick
what they
decide to look at like we they wrote
they work for us so why don't we just
give them what to look at they're an
appellate court
not a trial court so they still work for
the people right
but they're in appellate courts right so
the way it works is you can
file in court and have your trial and
then the judge issues their ruling
congratulations you're a citizen
you have that right now appeals courts
they can reject you and say the law was
upheld
so when the supreme court says we're not
going to look at it usually it's because
they're like this decision was legit
buy we you know we're not going to we're
not going to bother with it that
there you go usually but in this
situation in this situation it was
really different because
texas the lawsuit from the states it's
uh it's called original jurisdiction
meaning who does a state go to when
they're filing
a uh you know lawsuit against another
state they can't go to a circuit court
because a circuit might be
in one of these states or on totally
unrelated so they've they filed the
supreme court
alito and thomas believe they're
obligated to take up these claims
to represent this you know to oversee
these disputes between the states
but apparently trump's appointees
gorsuch uh
amy coney bear and kavanaugh did not
agree and felt that they have the right
to
say no to these to these uh cases
we'll see if anything comes of it i
think one of the one of the important
things people need to realize about
whether or not the election was stolen
or anything
right now we're well past the point of
the election
i don't think at this point the election
matters in any anyway all right
the media said joe biden won the
electoral college came and had their
official votes and they said joe biden
they voted for joe biden joe biden gets
the gets the uh
the electoral votes well what we're
talking about right now is trump versus
the establishment can trump win in this
ongoing fight
the numbers of votes don't matter as far
as i'm concerned okay you know why
we get a report out of antrim uh and
antrim in uh michigan
where a guy straight up says these
machines are designed to have massive
errors
like that that was his assessment and we
had hunter avalon on the show and he
said
i don't believe it effectively he said
this guy is a trump supporter and he's
crazy he's put out false information
before and i'm like great
that's exactly my point the left is
going to be like why would i believe
this report from a trump supporter and i
go
you're it's a great point why would i
believe anyone who's not a trump
supporter when they come to refute it in
which case all that really matters
confidence legitimacy and influence
trump wins if
more people believe in him than anything
else
i don't know if that's going to happen
especially with people like linwood and
sidney powell
really really hurting trump's legitimacy
like seriously hurting it
when regular people are not paying
attention and you get some crazy kraken
story
you know hugo chavez or whatever i'm
gonna be like what
what i don't know what is that that
sounds crazy to me and so that hurts
trump's legitimacy
if they came out and made a
constitutional argument about uh
changing the rules a regular person says
wow that's a you know interesting
constitution oh yeah violation of the
constitution i understand that
trump needs to convince more people
because right now i'll tell you this if
100 million people woke up today
in the you know or tomorrow morning and
all said trump is president
trump would be president regardless of
it like seriously
if everyone in this country just one day
said the constitution doesn't exist
then it wouldn't exist its power is held
in the fact that people swear an oath to
it that we
we believe in the system we have
confidence the system exists
and that's what matters so trump is
fighting a kind of battle to prove some
kind of legitimacy the reason it's going
through the courts
and the reason it's going to go to
january 6 when they dispute is to
use the system that exists now to assert
legitimacy
that's it but i'll tell you this they
say it's over
betfair right they do the they did
political betting i think they're based
in the uk
said december 14th the electoral college
voted joe biden has won the presidency a
bunch of trump supporters got really mad
started you know tweeting at him saying
what do you mean like they haven't even
counted the votes yet
and they're like well you have a problem
with it we'll revisit later the reason
betfair probably paid out is because
they want to get their taxes in before
the end of the year
you know their losses and their like i
guess the way you can put it is
they take all this money for bets and if
they hold on to it into the next year
that's all revenue plus
so they need those losses they need to
be like here's what we paid out and lost
we'll come back to it later if trump
somehow becomes president it might even
be kamal harris
i mean there's look joe biden was
coughing up a storm he's an old man
and he announced he's going to be taking
the covid vaccine
next week oh my god so uh anaphylaxis
yeah that's yeah that's publicly i think
he'll be fine but uh
i'm not saying he won't i'm not saying
he won't i'm just adding another layer
to that
he's gonna be doing that as well so
what's happening is
there's a system that exists there are
there are stamps on envelopes
certification right official governor's
seal that's the kind of thing
that a regular person looks at and says
i recognize that as legitimate
but what if someone came to you with a
seal that said you know
office of the the new you know what we
saw we saw a lawsuit
that went that signed on for the texas
loss
the texas lawsuit got two uh amicus
uh auditions from new california and new
nevada yeah what was that
states which do not exist yeah but what
if someone
believed it what if the media announced
what if every news outlet said
the state of new nevada now exists and
here's its territory people would be
like wow and they believe it
then when someone sues people would be
right there that is a thing right
so that's what the media has been
relentlessly saying joe biden's
president-elect even though
president-elect doesn't determine until
january 6.
they want him to be legitimized trump is
fighting for legitimacy
the best path for trump to get
legitimacy is on january 6 at this point
and it's extremely unlikely
maybe maybe what happens is that some
information comes out
you know from now until then and then
you have these republican electoral
candidates who cast their votes
procedurally
so then you know something flips and
then the count says you know republicans
support trump democrats support biden
there's a dispute it goes to supreme
court or whatever who knows trump ends
up winning something like that
it's using the system's legitimacy to
claim you are president but i tell you
i think that you know when they're
saying it's over now
then they're then they're saying but on
january 6 we'll see trump's final plan
it's like try it's not over election
wise until january 20th
when joe biden you know swears an oath
and he's sworn into the oval office and
all that stuff
and trump leaves what if trump doesn't
leave
he will leave if he's supposed to thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you